sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
Sie recht herzlich zur heutigen
Pressekonferenz hier im wunderschönen
Mistelbach begrüßen der Vorstand zu
meiner Linken die Frau Landeshauptfrau
von Niederösterreich Johanna
michelleitner und die
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Danner
Frau Landeshauptfrau ich würde sie um
ihre begrüßungswort der suchen viel
herzlichen Dank für die charmante
einmoderation sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin liebe Claudia sehr
geehrter Herr Militärkommandant
Stellvertreter sehr geehrter patellas
Kommandant geschätzte
Verantwortungsträger des
österreichischen Bundesheeres meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren der Medien
wir haben uns heute in der
wolfratskaserne eingefunden dem zuhause
des dritten aufklärungs und andere
Artillerie bataillon
immer das sind die Augen und Ohren
dieser Brigade aber heute sind diese
Augen und Ohren
wohl auf das wichtigste gerichtet
nämlich auf dem Militärstandort in der
Stadt Mistelbach denn heute werden wir
einen weitreichende Pläne präsentieren
wo ich mich jetzt schon herzlich
bedanken darf bei der Frau
Bundesministerin bei Claudia Tanner dass
diese Präsentation heute hier möglich
ist und zwar werden wir heute bekannt
geben gemeinsam das ist hier eben eine
ganz klare Entscheidung geben wird dass
hier dieser Standort verlegt wird auf
die auf dem garnisonsübungsplatz toten
Hauer eine neue Kaserne wird dort
errichtet und erbaut das heißt eine neue
Kaserne hier für das österreichische
Bundesliga und somit meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ist dieser
Tag für uns natürlich ein Freudentag ein
Freudentag für die gesamte Republik
Österreich ein Freudentag im speziell
natürlich für Niederösterreich für die
wunderbare in der Stadt Mistelbach
natürlich für die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten
ein Freudentag aber natürlich in einer
äußerst herausfordernden Zeit und werden
wie ich von herausfordernder Zeit
spreche denke ich natürlich an den Krieg
in der Ukraine damit sehr viele
menschlichen Leid verbunden ist aber vor
allem auch mit nachhaltigen Folgen für
uns alle und gerade diese kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung mitten in Europa hat
auch zu einem verstärkten
Sicherheitsbewusstsein in der
Bevölkerung geführt Menschen wollen mehr
an Sicherheit wollen ein starkes
österreichisches Bundesheer das heißt
die globale Sicherheitsstruktur
Architektur als auch die heran vor die
Herausforderungen haben sich massiv
verändert unsere Bundesministerin ist es
die auf diese Herausforderung
letztendlich auch agiert und vor allem
noch reagiert durch ein herzliches Danke
sagen darf vom danke
gratulieren darf
die Erhöhung umzusetzen und vor allem
auch durchzusetzen 16 Milliarden Euro
die nächsten vier Jahre die hier
investiert werden sollen 16 Milliarden
Euro für das österreichische Bundesheer
eine Summe die unglaublich die
unglaublichen
nicht österreichische Bundesheer auch
lange gewartet hat daher für dieses
umsetzen und Durchsetzen von
Bundesminister die ein ganz großes und
herzliches Dankeschön du führst das
österreichische Bundesheer mit dieser
Investition auf einen guten Weg in die
Zukunft
Damen und Herren damit wird natürlich
auch gestärkt dass
Sicherheitsbewusstsein und generell
gestärkt der Militärstandort
Österreicher vor allem auch
Niederösterreich mit diesem mit dieser
Entscheidung Niederösterreich ist ein
wichtiger Militärstandard mit 23
Kasernen und 5.500 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten und somit ein wichtiger
Bestandteil der gesamten
sicherheitsfamilie Niederösterreich sie
wissen das gerade das österreichische
Bundesheer mit allen anderen
Blaulichtorganisationen bestens
kooperiert wenn
Zusammenarbeit funktioniert auf Zuruf
und wir können uns in jeder kritischen
Situation immer auf das österreichische
Bundesheer verlassen und sie sind vor
allem auch eine wichtige Brücke in die
Gesellschaft ja meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ein Niederösterreich
ein Militärstandard der sich über eine
starke Achse in allen Himmelsrichtungen
erstreckt eine Achse auf die wir stolz
sind vom ja Kommando in Wiener Neustadt
über die Pioniere in Melk die Flieger in
langen Leber bis hier zu den Aufklärung
und der Artillerie hier in Mistelbach
und heute im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
schlagen wir ein neues Kapitel auf hier
in Mistelbach ein neues Kapitel für das
österreichische Bundesliga
eine unglaublich lebenswerte und
lebenswerte Stadt mit sehr vielen
Wirtschaft und vor allem auch
Landwirtschaft vor allem aber ein
Gesundheit
man dort um Bildungsstandard denke hier
an das Klinikum hier in Mistelbach denke
an den dislozierten pflegelehrgang der
ganz neu installiert worden ist bis hin
natürlich zur neuen landesfachhochschule
Fachschule die wir jetzt erst eröffnet
haben bis hin natürlich Mistelbach ist
auch eine Kulturstadt eine Kulturstadt
wenn ich an das Mammuts denke im
speziellen auch an das nitschmuseum das
vor allem eine Leuchtkraft weit über die
Grenzen Niederösterreich und vor allem
auch Österreichs hat Mistelbach ist aber
vor allem auch ein traditionsreicher und
strategischer wichtiger
Militärstandort wo bis zu 300
Grundwehrdiener für ja ausgebildet
werden
Heimat ist wichtigen kaderverbandes und
derzeit 270 Arbeitsplätze hier in
Mistelbach das heißt die
mistelbacherinnen und Mistelbacher
schätzen diese Kaserne unglaublich
natürlich auch die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten aber wissen natürlich auch dass
dieser Standard auch bisher mit einigen
Nachteilen verbunden war mit Nachteil
das vor allem diese Kaserne natürlich
fast in der Stadt ist wo hier natürlich
auch immer wieder es zu
Lärmbelästigungen gekommen ist natürlich
auch eine Kaserne die durch Trend ist
durch die Bahnstrecke wo das natürlich
für viele eine logistische
Herausforderungen in den letzten Jahren
bedeutet hat und natürlich einen
Standort der zu klein geworden ist und
ein Standard der vor allem auch in die
Jahre gekommen ist und daher ist diese
Entscheidung der Frau Bundesminister
einfach die einzige richtige und vor
allem auch wichtige Entscheidung ja
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ein
mit dieser Entscheidung kommt es zu
einer Neuerung kommt es zu einer neuen
Infrastruktur auf der Höhe der Zeit wird
vor allem auch genug Raum um Platz
geschaffen für den Einsatz und
Katastropheneinsatz wird vor allem auch
eine Andockstelle geschaffen für andere
zivile Organisationen wenn es britischen
Situationen wie eine fleckout kommt das
heißt hier wird vorgedacht und
nachgedacht und dementsprechend auch die
Infrastruktur angepasst und deswegen ist
diese Verlegung die neu Errichtung
dieser Kaserne die einzig wichtig und
richtige Entscheidungen für eine
herausfordernden Zeit ja meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren es wird hier
aber nicht nur eine die eine
Infrastruktur für das österreichische
Bundesheer geschaffen auf der Höhe der
Zeit sondern dadurch ergeben sich
natürlich auch neue Zukunftsperspektiven
hier für die Stadt Mistelbach neue
Perspektiven wo man Andenken kann hier
diese Region diese dieses Areal auch zu
entwickeln für soziale Einrichtungen für
Wohnbau oder für Gewerbe all das muss
natürlich in Zukunft auch nachgedacht
und vorgedacht werden wo ich fest davon
überzeugt bin dass der Herr
Bürgermeister hier seine Visionen
diskutieren wird hier in der Stadt und
dann auch zu wichtigen richtigen
Entscheidungen kommt zu Entscheidungen
die eben auf Wohlgefallen seitens der
mistelbacherinnen und mistelbacherfallen
in diesem Sinne darf ich mich noch
einmal bei der Frau Bundesministerin
Claudia Tanner herzlich bedanken für
diese Entscheidung dass hier ein Neubau
einer Kaserne geplant und vor allem auch
umgesetzt wird das hier Fall Visionen da
sind die auch umgesetzt sind wo immer
wie auch unterstützen können tun wir das
gerne und darf mich vor allem für die
gute Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
österreichischen Bundesheer und im Land
Niederösterreich bedanken aber auch
zwischen dem Land Niederösterreich im
Bundeswehr und der Stadt Mistelbach der
Bürgermeister ist wieder einmal für dich
ein guter Tag ein wichtiger Tag
eine Institution auf der Höhe der Zeit
bekommt die dir wieder mal so gut wie
null Euro kostet alles Gute
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Landeshauptstadt Frau
sehr geehrter Herr Bürgermeister
Stellvertreter
Kommandanten Soldatinnen Soldaten
herauffahrt Seiler sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren der Medien die Frau
Landeshauptfrau hat es angesprochen wir
leben in herausfordernden Zeiten die
auch als Zeitenwende insbesondere seit
dem Ukraine Krieg bezeichnet werden
können so vieles das undenkbar
erschienen ist ist eingetreten oder gilt
als sehr wahrscheinlich daher ist es
umso wichtiger dass wir uns als
österreichisches Bundesheer zum Schutz
und zur Sicherheit der Bevölkerung gut
aufstellen nur ein modern und gut
ausgestattetes Bundeswehr kann unser
Land Verteidigung kann all seine
zahlreichen vielfältigen Aufgaben
erfüllen und ich freue mich wirklich
sehr die Frau Landeshauptfrau als
angesprochen dass uns jetzt wirklich ein
Budget zur Verfügung stellt das ist auch
möglich macht insgesamt 16 Milliarden
Euro das diese vielen Investitionen
möglich macht wir haben das seit den
Nationalfeiertag bezeichnet als Mission
vorwärts das ist ein Aufbauplan für das
Bundesheer der über die nächsten zehn
Jahre hinweg geht wo wir zum einen
investieren in die Mobilität der
Einsatzkräfte in den Schutz und die
Wirkung unserer Soldatinnen und Soldaten
wir werden moderne Ausrüstung Waffen und
Gerät beschaffen aber wir brauchen als
modernes Bundesheer vor allem auch eine
gute Infrastruktur das heißt wir werden
und müssen unsere Kasernen auf
Vordermann bringen und ich glaube gerade
Niederösterreich das für uns wohl eines
der einer der wichtigsten
Militärstandorte ist da haben wir sehr
vieles vor wir haben ja insgesamt 80
Liegenschaften die Kasernen die 23 sind
schon angesprochen worden und hier in
Mistelbach ist eine ganz besonders
wichtige die alte wolfratskaserne wenn
wir uns hier umsehen die hat ohne
Zweifel gute Dienste geleistet aber man
sieht schon auch eines sie ist in die
Jahre gekommen und wir brauchen moderne
Unterkünfte und ein modernes
Arbeitsumfeld unserer Soldatinnen und
Soldaten das waren schon lange
Überlegungen die wir angestellt haben
und ich will das an dieser Stelle auch
betonen die wir gemeinsam mit dem Land
Niederösterreich mit der Landeshauptfrau
mit dem Bürgermeister angestellt haben
und dann zum Entschluss gekommen sind
dass nur durch einen Neubau alles
modernen gestaltet werden kann an dieser
Stelle ist festzuhalten das ist seit 40
Jahren der erste Neubau einer Kaserne
hier in Niederösterreich tatsächlich
eine historische Entscheidung wir werden
das was an Nachteil noch da ist der
Bürgermeister für die Anrainer das auch
von der Landeshauptfrau schon
angesprochen worden ist damit wirklich
auch beseitigen können wenn es um
Lärmemissionen geht wenn es um das
durchaus auch hohe Verkehrsaufkommen
geht es wird im Raum Toten Haare
wirklich eine Kaserne entstehen die
räumlich dann auch direkt an das
Übungsgelände angeschlossen ist und ich
bin auch überzeugt davon dass das
regional für eine Wertschöpfung sorgen
wird dass das auch eine Möglichkeit ist
hier wirklich eine überregionale
Bedeutung auch zu bekommen als Kaserne
weil diese dann auch ein Backup
darstellen soll für die künftige
sicherheitsinsel langen Leben ja und die
neue Kaserne in Mistelbach die wird dann
600 Männern und Frauen Platz bieten 300
Personen werden ständig präsent sein
aber es wird auch genügend Raum
geschaffen werden für die milizverbände
ja wie weit sind wir jetzt damit und was
sind die nächsten Schritte im kommenden
Jahr
2023 beginnen die ersten Maßnahmen
widmungsbehörden Verfahren
umweltverfahren Bodenanalysen 2024 dann
die detaillierten Planungen und der
konkrete Baubeginn ist dann 20 25
insgesamt werden wir investieren vor
Landeshauptfrau 150 Millionen Euro in
diese neue Kaserne wir werden dann in
ein paar Minuten von Herrn Herres
immobiliendirektorhofer Zeiler einiges
dazu erfahren ich glaube was auch
wichtig ist und woran man sieht dass so
etwas nur im Miteinander möglich ist
zwischen dem Land und der Gemeinde ist
dass es auch um die Nachnutzung des
Areals gehen wird das wird in weiterer
Folge ja eben aus der militärischen
Nutzung entlassen werden und dann als
entwicklungsliegenschaft im Rahmen der
generellen Stadtentwicklung weiter
gestaltet werden ich bin überzeugt davon
dass uns dieses gemeinsam gelingen wird
und für diese Region wirklich auch
wichtige Impulse bringen wird sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir wollen zur
Modernisierung des Bundesheeres in ganz
Österreich insbesondere aber in
Niederösterreich militärische Immobilien
effizient nutzen letztendlich geht es
immer auch um mehr gemeinnützen für uns
alle ich freue mich wirklich sehr auf
die Verwirklichung dieses Bauprojektes
ich darf nicht ganz herzlich bedanken
bei dir Frau Landeshauptfrau für deine
schon aufgezeiten als die Bedeutung des
österreichischen Bundesheeres noch nicht
für alle ersichtlich war und die
notwendigen budgetären Ausstattungen
auch bei dir Herr Bürgermeister für das
gute Miteinander und darf dann schon an
Dich übergeben danke schön
gestalten Sie mir vielleicht noch einen
Zusatz oder eine Zusammenfassung ich
glaube in unser weiteren Namen bin fest
davon überzeugt dass diese Entscheidung
der Frau Bundesministerin einfach zu
einer Windsituation für alle Beteiligten
führt auf der einen Seite erhält das
österreichische Bundesheer eine
Infrastruktur auf der Höhe der Zeit und
zum anderen ergeben sich hier für die
Stadt Mistelbach neue
Entwicklungsperspektiven und vor allem
für die Menschen hier in der Region
deswegen noch einmal ein herzliches
Dankeschön dass hier am Standort
Mistelbach 150 Millionen Euro investiert
werden und ich kann versprechen dass wir
seines Landes als auch seit der Gemeinde
gerade in der Planung
zu auch äußerst kooperativ sein werden
so wie wir das gewohnt sind
[Applaus]
Bürgermeister bieten und den Herrn
Hofrat Seiler bitte zu mir
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin sehr
geehrte Frau Landeshauptfrau sehr
geehrter Herr Bürgermeister
Soldatinnen und Soldaten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
Ausgangssituation war eine
ballungsraumstudie die ergeben hat dass
der Standort hier im Stadtgefüge
Mistelbach einige Hürden bringt mit sich
bringt es wurde bereits angesprochen
hierbei wurde betrachtet die
Verkehrsanbindung sowohl die
militärische zivile und die
Übungsmöglichkeiten auch die
Einsatzmöglichkeiten Vorbereitungen für
die Miliz das hat ergeben dass man die
Kaserne hier in den vier Kilometer
nördlichen Bereich des
gruppenübungsplatzes und
befestigungsplatzes verlegen war
das Gelände
bietet an dass man auf den Talbereich
hier in den beiden Bereichen nun Lager
und Übungsplatz
gefechtsübungsplatz eine Tarte Bereich
hat hier wird der schwere Gerät die
schwere Lasten und das hohe
Verkehrsaufkommen hinein interpretiert
und hineingegeben und das Gelände dazu
zum mundlager bietet an dass sie
Übungsfläche des Verbandes nicht
geschmälert wird
zwei Ideen durchlaufen diese Kasernen
das eine ist die zentrale
Erschließungsachse
und der zweite die zweite Idee ist die
Idee der durchlaufenden
ebenenschichtlinien
das bietet eine Typ der kompakten
modernen Kasernen mit kurzen Wegen die
Idee der zentralen Entwicklungslinie und
durch Bewegung bedeutet hier in einer
alleeform können alle
Versorgungsleitungen und Medien hier
zentral erschlossen werden die Gebäude
werden links und rechts hier aufgefasst
die Kompanie Gebäude sind so gestaltet
dass sie in diesen Treppenbau so
angeordnet sind dass das Gebäude des
jeweiligen anderen Kompanie Gebäude hier
zu dient als Übungsfläche als
Ausbildungsstätte zu dienen durch
Brücken Wege und Stege entstehen
kompakte Wege kurze Wege auch dass sie
Gebäude untereinander alle umschlossen
sind das Ziel
wird letztendlich sein hier von diesen
angedachten Antritte Platz hier als
Fahnenmasten dargestellt fahrendenplatz
dargestellt zum Ausbildungsgelände eine
Sichtbereich haben und damit die Kaserne
modern und Physik
umsetzen zu können sowohl die Leitungen
erschließen können im rechten Bereich
hier um in links ansehen sind die
Versorgungsleitungen Verpflegung und
dieser Bereich danke schön
[Applaus]